bienvenue vous écoutez envergure est ici
on parle de tous les jeunes basketteurs
promis à un bel avenir que ce soit en
france en europe et aux états unis notre
credo on regarde beaucoup de matches
interview et on évalue ses prospects sur
notre site envergure point ces eaux on a
recensé plusieurs milliers de joueurs
avec évaluation écrite mais ici à
l'audio on va plutôt confrontés nos
opinions et donc on papote vous écoute
et de préférence avec notre site ouvert
à côté bon épisode à vous si c'est bien
abonnez-vous si c'est très bien commenté
et si c'est génial partager
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous pour ce
nouvel épisode d'envergure papote c'est
hugues qui vous parle et je suis en
compagnie de l'incroyable de
l'inimitable pierre comment tu vas salut
je ne sais pas si je suis inimitable
mais très content d'être là en tout cas
en tout cas tu t'es rendu indispensable
c'est dans des temps je suis revenu sur
la tumeur tu m'as laissé faire le
speaker met en route le voit un peu
partout d'ailleurs y'a
contourne la démission hier tu as tourné
un super planète losc est
gas et l'émission numéro 2 avec deux
coaches était incroyable donc voilà
avant d'écouter cette émission-là de
papote n'hésitez pas à les regarder le
planet draft et puis à nous donner des
retours on voit de tout contrat dure 2 0
ben ça rien deux heures c'est rien a
tant donné quand tu suis envergure est
la terre des rentes ne rate rien du tout
faire aimer ça dans la voiture qui me
donne ta douche aux sports où tu veux
mais tu regardes la démission c'est un
en manque un aujourd'hui si on se
retrouve c'est pas pour parler de coach
pas pour parler d'espoir français mais
pour parler d'un prospect m biya qui est
maintenant entré en biais petite session
de rattrapage un mec ou moi j'ai déjà
été dithyrambique dessus mais on va
essayer d'être un peu d'objectivité
on va parler de kahone thomass
thomas est ce que cannes c'est à cames
c'est la vraie question
à toi la chirurgie le relais sur owen
voilà dessus camacho dicton c'est une
addiction chez que toi tu étais à ses
hôtes une avait adopté de manger un
petit peu plus bas de mémoire
kamto masse alors c'est qui c'est un
arrière qui jouait à alessio louisiana
state university pour paul waide
c'est avant tout un gros shooter un
énorme shooter c'était le meilleur
freshman en termes de poids
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable avec le
ballon qui a un vrai attrait pour le
pour le panier quoi c'est l'impression
qu'ils voient que ça et il a utilisé il
a été utilisé le code pour ça c'est un
mec qui peut filocher à 8,9 m elle pose
aucun problème
voilà un gros gros potentiel offensif
est d'ailleurs elle a commencé à montrer
un petit peu en présaison
moment une bille est
assez clair que ce qu'on peut dire sur
cameron de masse et qu'il a pas peur peu
importe le contexte je peux le mettre
n'importe où il va prendre ses 45 tirs
par match en être ça dépend des soirées
revenir mais voilà une très grosse
comptant sur lui avant de parler des
points forts des projections et cetera
est ce qu'on peut faire parce qu'on est
chez envergure quand même un petit poids
sur les mensurations du jeu et ses
qualités athlétiques au global ouais
bien sûr
donc qu'un tomassi je n'ai pas bêtise
c'est un mec 93 pour 95 kilos donc c'est
un garçon qui est pas très haut mais qui
est déjà quand même bien trinquer au
niveau notamment des épaules et des
cuisses
un monsieur qui a dû gérer
et donc voilà si comme moi il me faisait
un petit peu en comparaison physique à
la base on fait dépenser un petit peu
eric gordon en début de carrière de ce
joueur de deuxième arrière traître a pu
parce que pour moi c'est vraiment un pur
ça peut-être qu on en discutera mais
pour moi c'est uniquement 1 2
voilà c'est un garçon qui a été présent
au sol
a forcément le plus arriéré même si
c'est tout à fait correct
moi je te rejoins totalement alors
effectivement c'est pourquoi pour
appeler la petite envergure il n'y a pas
de chiffres vraiment défini nous notre
côté on a comprenait pas trouvé ça aussi
entre 1,96 et 1,98 donc voilà on a une
envergure qui est un peu supérieur mais
ce n'est pas sa qualité première il n'ya
pas des bras démentiellement long comme
maintenant les mêmes de les avoir je
suis d'accord sur le fait qu' il a un un
poste définissent en arrière et que ce
sera en arrière uniquement par ses
mensurations j'allais un peu de chic et
choc cameron thomass avant lé sioux ce
qui est drôle c'est qu'ils étaient des
clés comme un mec assez aérien mais avec
un manque de puissance alors à elle
échoue comme tu l'as dit ouais à l'ailé
sur comme tu l'as dit on a vu un mec
très tank et dans le bas du corps avec
des cuisses fait vraiment des bonnes
grosses cuisses et moi et m'a vraiment
impressionné sur le la puissance en bas
du corps j'ai peu d'eux j'ai peu de
comparaisons avec d'autres jours cette
année où j'ai trouvé aux titres eux
aussi dominant sur ce secteur-là sur
cette partie là du physique et du coup
elle a un peu moins de qualités
aériennes
mais je pense que maintenant on est
assez d'accord là dessus en verdure on
préfère la mecque avec des capable de
traverser du contact à très puissant
avec des bons fondamentaux bas du corps
plutôt qu'un qu'un tueur marsupial pour
commencer une carrière nba
ouais après c'est difficile différents
profils épices fin vers a les défauts de
ses qualités à chaque fois qu'on les tue
en pareil ouais tu sinon il serait
numéro un draft voilà les t bonds
partout voilà c'est que là
on va faire un petit point sur ce que
cameron thomas c'était dessous parce que
les sous c'était quand même un contexte
très particulier que toi tu es le
spécialiste envergure au niveau de la s
ici donc c'est une allumette genre une
décision est grosse conférence
c'est une conférence qui est surtout
réputé pour football américain de base
mais lentement circuit basket c'est
quand même très très sérieux avec des
profils athlétique vraiment développé je
pense que on s'il n'y a pas vraiment de
conférence où les mecs ont aussi aussi
tant qu elle physiquement et l ess your
way équipe très particulière parce que
l'équipe présentée sur un seul côté du
terrain en fait ouais il sort très bons
joueurs aussi
c'est une équipe où le bon était très
très peu investi il y avait un apport du
banc qui était à chaque fois dérisoire
et c'est ce qui les a vraiment limité
après ce soit en tournoi finale de
conférence ou à la march madness dire
qu'il y avait zéro à bord du banc
c'était tout sur sur le cinq majeur
quasiment
vous voilà c'est dit on avait des
joueurs qui à l'image de cannes tournage
fait beaucoup incarne thomas savare a
rappelé un peu ses stats ses 24 matches
joués l'année dernière soit 34 minutes
par match est assez énorme pour un
freshman mon enfant rappelle dont trois
fois 3,4 rebonds 4 passes pascaline
style par match et quasiment pas de 0,2
bloque donc il tournait à 32
5% à 3 points 40 % aux tirs en général
88% sur la vie
voilà donc c'est un vous méprenez pas
c'est un shooteur se veut dire le 32%
c'est un mec qui a arrosé toute ans qui
prenait des mauvais tir mais qui était
aussi incités à prendre ces mauvais tir
dans le sens et les sioux c'était une
équipe qui jouait c'était une somme
d'individualités ou sajoo et iso sorriso
sur réseau c'était vraiment c'était un
coup c'était le djia monte smart un coup
cédé watford un coup c'était comme
thomass et c'était comme ça tout le
temps et pour trois une équipe qui se
courait pas beaucoup il y avait beaucoup
plus de mal quand tu la vis de l'autre
côté du terrain
ouais alors effectivement c'est une
équipe qui scorait nommément qui joue
très très vite avec des des très mauvais
tir cameron thomass juste pour rappeler
comme tu as dix plus gros scores parmi
les crashs même c'est le plus gros
volume de tiers de l'équipe et de loin
et de vraiment loin cameron daumas il a
pris sa sentir cette saison le deuxième
c'est très drôle watford ce faux mort
qui avait aussi été drafté un drafting
métier aussi parti à la draft qui a un à
prix 350 et y en a 150 tir de plus et la
grosse majorité de ces tirs la céder à
la cdc des grosses bombes avec deux
défenseurs dessus mais lui sans tain
c'est pas son problème
comme tu l'as dit aussi de type stefan
pas un mec qui défendent dans l'équipe
on à tonga dans lequel on allait pas les
apprenants dans un oeil d'or doivent
donc je vous invite à regarder cet
épisode sur darius des skis le pauvre
était entourée de mecs une dizaine on
fera ça peut-être plus tard tout
trader et fanta défend pas déjà voté
smart genre coach des tests qui a pu
avoir une une option de tout est alors
faudrait que vérifier peut-être que je
dis des conneries mais je crois que le
pit l'avait proposé un tour et contracte
carrefour mini des gars comme moi tu
fasses fois qu'il signe en tout est
obligés sinon au niveau quo est forte
c'est sûr ils assignent eux entouraient
aube les hearts qui veut pas prix
marteau
mais
on voit quand même des joueurs de
qualité mais il faut pas d'effort je te
propose on va sur le point fort de
camembert tomates rondes est un peu
rentré dedans ouais chutant de gros
volumes mais très puissant toi qu'est-ce
qui te pour toi c'est quoi vraiment le
point d'accès pour la dénigrer -
cameroun passe au niveau supérieur pour
moi son projet axé sa capacité à scorer
c'est un scoreur naturel c'est un garçon
qui fait ça
de façon évidente qui a besoin de
personne
et c'est un mec je vois pas comment ils
ne mettraient pas des points s'il joue
en nba en fait c'est il a le foot il a
cette capacité
à finir au cercle quand même malgré tout
même si quelquefois on l'a vu aussi
aller s'empaler dans les défenses
adverses
comme tu a rappelé dans une conférence
où il ya quand même pour reprendre
l'expression de nico des bobards quoi
donc
c'est une conférence où il ya ouvert où
il ya mille state où william kentucky
van der betteraves wallace et des
équipes qui calme ce soir 2 1 donc on
voit après on mois sa carte d'entrée
c'est ça c'est son talent offensif il a
la capacité à acheter à 8,9 m comme je
vous le disais au début et
ça dans la nba moderne je pense que ça
ça at il tout de suite en fait ouais
c'est bien c'est clair moi ce qui la
presse a peut-être le plus c'est qu'un
droit de thomas c'est parce qu'on voit à
shooter de gros volumes serra haendel
fou c'est un deuil qui est déjà très
développé fuites sur les deux mains
capable de finir dès demain ça mec quand
il a la balle en main ici change de
rythme alors on l'a dit ce n'est pas
forcément le plus athlétique mais c'est
très bien utilisés sont des penseurs et
c'est très bien ralentir voilà comme je
les dis changé de mains pour voir rayer
les au niveau des appuis il a un step
back il a un gros step il peut s'arrêter
feinter faire sauter le défenseur est
remonté pour trouver des fautes parce
qu'il adore faire tomber des fautes
cameron thomass oued ailleurs quatre ans
il avait su nos spécialités moi un truc
qui me rendais fou c'était ce côté a à
chaque fois et qui prenait un tir à mi
distance soit aidé d'un mec à vouloir
écarter les gens pour prouver qu'il est
faux je suis très très curieux de voir
s'il va faire ça aurait une bille et
surtout avec les nouvelles arrivent tous
soient apparus cela est assez marrant
moi ouais exactement là ont tourné un
épisode avec julien elle a pas si
longtemps sur just christopher un petit
hamburger pas potosi et josh christopher
avait ce côté là aussi à mettre la jambe
en avant et on se disait que ma avec les
nouvelles règles c'était plus forcément
possible alors cameron thomass lui ont
pas revenir dessus plus tard mais il
al'avantage de jouer dans l'équipe de
james harden qui pour le court savoir
faire tomber des fautes il est pas trop
mauvais en théorie guerrière bing
on verra plus tard mais il s'est
d'ailleurs tombée des fautes et kevin
durant qui est pas non plus le mec le
plus grandir le plus gentil de la
likouala
il est tombé il ya tombé à domicile fait
toi toi une [ __ ] toi aussi tu toi
aussi aura bien qu est bien sympa fait
plaisir
alors l'arbitré comment qu'on lui dit on
lui dit si fusible ses actifs parce que
l'an dernier à et les sioux voilà pour
pour la stat il prenait
donc pardon un lancer franc pour un tir
tenté ouais c'est ce que j'ai dit
rasmussen c'est à s'attaquer à ces
folles et pourtant c'est pas un mec qui
va beaucoup au mastic alors il est
capable parce qu'il est très puissant
bas et que voilà il ay national de cette
variation il avait que 16 % de cette
cire près du panier pour une belle
réussite mais avoir beaucoup de beaucoup
de couleurs mi distance beaucoup de 3.2
contestées peut-être une évolution à
suivre dans sa carrière nba pour revenir
quand même sur l'autre côté du terrain
défensivement
hormis le contexte qui était à frais aux
personnes défendent et que ce n'était
pas forcément de consignes de défendre
est ce que tu penses que cameroun thomas
s'il a les outils pour défendre et la
volonté de défendre plus tard
alors ils vont défendre moi j'ai
honnêtement ce n'est qu'il que j'ai
beaucoup regardé l'année dernière j'ai
trouvé les mecs à une évolution au fil
de l'année esprit les mages devenez
important plus ici limitée alors c'est
pas un bon défenseur loin de là mais il
faisait les efforts parce qu'au début de
saison il n'est pas du tout quoi il
laisser partir les mecs en pack d'or il
dormait
limites mais qui s'excusait pas où il
s'en foutait pas vraiment il est là
derrière est secouée et au fur et à
mesure on a senti qu'ils étaient un
petit peu concernés
comme les stocks c'est quand même pas
terrible a peut-être falloir que je me
mette un peu pour moi savez ça le
facteur tu vas faire va déterminer son
temps j'ai en fait ils qui va être
capable de tenir à minima faire le
travail minimum en défense si c'est oui
franchement il peut avoir pas mal de
minutes dès sa première année quoi moi
c'est un facteur c'est le souhait mais
en tout cas ça c'est là que comme on dit
il va jouer avec des mecs qui défonce et
pas la qualité première james harden n'y
ait pas connu pour défendre à voir s'il
peut jouer avec les rurbains qu'encore
une fois on sait pas si des fonds mais
facile à jouer pardon mais il n'y a pas
d'efforts non plus khairi patti smith
sur les postes arrières c'est pas non
plus ruraux défenseur même si c'est un
mâle a collectivement quant aux masques
il va devoir on aime bien dire souvent
il a les outils pour mais il faudrait le
faire je suis d'accord sur les matchs
sur les fins de matches serrés et sur
les matchs de deux conférences la
délinquance ou cameroun thomas sur
pick'n roll tu te dis bon ba l'attaquant
est pas encore passé s'arrêtent panier
et non le mec il bouge pas cameron
tomassi par sa puissance en bas du corps
par ciné jouissent pas resaler
latéralité et parfois l'art a un
physique bien développée dans une
conférence de mammouth stopper le mec
d'en face et j'étais en mode à oui
d'accord la can autres comment thomas
s'ils me montrent qui peut qui peuvent
faire des stops latéralement il est
intéressant il est puissant bas il a des
bras correcte sans être élite il a des
mains assez agile on voit qu'il faut
quand même une interception alors même
si je joue pas mal de la lgv est pas mal
aline de passe il ya quand même des des
touches dans les mains de l'attaquant
quand il veut donc il a des des outils
physiques et parfois une montre et la
motivation pour être un défenseur
correct sur l'homme parce que je suis
loin du ballon on va vous voyez il l'a
jamais fait quoi moi je les ai jamais dû
des fondements du bon il est pas
concentré dit ou non après moi je suis
un petit peu moins optimiste que toi sur
le côté capacité à le faire en fait moi
je sur sa latéralité mois n'a pas montré
grand-chose principe pas vu grand chose
justement sur ça est ce qu'il est
capable de faire je sais pas après même
sur les outils moi je trouve que les
outils seront pas d'un fait qui m'ont
aidé à bien se succèdent côté puissance
le seul qui peut être intéressant
justement s'il ya des switchs et du jeu
post bailly l'âge partis poids et roman
même s'il n'est pas très grand et tout
est plutôt intéressant sur ce domaine là
mais
sa capacité à bouger face à des athlètes
nba moi j'ai gagné un buzz d'or
huawei tu crois pas dans cette justement
dans la latéralité dans ses variations
de rythme
je trouve pas il perd explosif c1 les
deux corées mais pour moi il est pas
hyper explosif un mois ci pour cela
demandé des bons fondamentaux
fondamentaux au niveau des pieds je
trouve qu'il arrive vraiment à changer
vite ses appuis pieds tu vois dans
l'argile et vue sur tout ça en attaque
forcément puisque c'était le secteur
était plus développés n'est plus le plus
exposé voilà je trouve que quand tu es
capable d'avoir ce vraiment ce jeu de
pieds et retrouver ton équilibre très
facilement avec une bonne gestion de son
corps parce que voilà il maîtrise son
corps cameroun thomass moi je me dis que
là il ya vraiment des choses
intéressantes pour des fonds maintenant
comme tu dire on n'a pas non plus eu sur
des grosses séquences et aux non pas
d'athlètes mbia qui sont quand même bien
supérieur avec plus rapide plus vite
donc moi ça va être à observer très
rapidement on est clairement dans mon
coin franchement c'est le jeu je le
redis mais c'est quelque chose qui va
vraiment surtout soyez premier en
première année faire en sorte qu'ils
joueront pas bien sûr il ya le contexte
des nets après ça c'est autre chose mais
s'il est capable d'augmenter
continuer sa progression vaillard les
montées en puissance quand même sur ce
côté défensif au delà de la saison il
est capable aussi de continuer sur ça et
je pense qu'il est il aura pas d'aidés
minute
mal à les partants là-dessus partons
là-dessus contexte collectif alors draft
et honnête drafté fans premier tour ça
c'est drôle parce qu'ils étaient ils
étaient les 25e
du top 100 et espionnent les drafté
danse et dans ses environs lors de son
oraison la
cameroun thomas scott thomas silane eu
une carte à jouer cette année parce que
on sait que les nets sont une équipe qui
vont sûrement faire du log management
ils l'ont fait tous l'an dernier avec
khairi avec dwayne 'the avec arden pour
l'instant caverne où on sait pas si on
va jouer donc à peut-être dix minutes
aller gratter là dessus et nuit il a
fait une excellente summer league où il
a sali absolument tout le monde une
bonne pré saison où il a été
incandescent donc pour toi c'est quoi sa
projection là sur jean la prochaine
année petits tas de cholet sur le
contrat ou qui sont les trois quatre
prochaines années
moi je pense que la première année c'est
un joueur qui va
enchaîner les dnp les 28 minutes le
match d'après justement à cause de
management de steve nash je pense que ça
va être un peu cela donc il va faire des
cartons je suis quasiment sûr c'est un
mec qui imitera de saison plusieurs fois
plus de 20 points ça j'ai vraiment pas
trop de doute sur ça mais je ne sais pas
si il va être je ne vont pas utiliser de
façon régulière en fait on sait que ça
va être des moments certains matches et
sait où il aura vraiment sa chance et
sur d'autres pas du tout
ouais donc l'état sait vraiment si une
des deux stars est pas là
cameron tomassi joue si les deux stars
elles sont là donc je parle des deux
stars arrière un pas qui est la star de
l'équipe 1 mais si arvine hoegaarden
sont pas là ils jouent pas réussir ici
les deux sont présents
lui joue pas je pense qu'ils passent pas
une pas timide c'est sûr que va t-il se
jouera
derrière yaki sur les postes arrières
jason carter brouillonne mais pour ce
droit il a beaucoup plus jouer à l'ale
ces derniers temps on les marie être est
ce que est ce que serait ce que voilà
est-ce que cameron tomassi peut pas
aller bouffer même bruit parce que
johary c'est pareil il va plus jouer
trois générations ouais
pas grand monde derrière quoi ouais bah
après et quand même des joueurs
expérimentés je pense que bastien il est
aussi capable de jouer en deux fois fin
même si peut pas défendre face on ne
peut pas défenseur brestois n'ont pas
grand chose mais mais voilà après je
pense que vraiment
dans et ce serait pas forcément négatif
pour lui en plus de ça 2 justement avoir
le temps
de s'intégrer petit à petit comme ça
mais en ayant quand même des vrais des
vrais fin des matches où tu as vraiment
du temps
c'est pas mal aussi dans le
développement de ce genre de choses même
pourquoi pas de temps en temps si vous
vraiment pas essayer parce que le bas
tout le monde est là et que les rives
d'un mois de voyage vous des matches et
que faire quelques tours djelic histoire
de garder la main sa voix là mais
franchement voilà moi c'est je m'attends
à sa trousse rappelle tout à il joua
famille par quatre
équipiers
élu rookie of the year
ouais ouais je te rejoins alors
effectivement j'aimerais qu'ils jouent
un maximum et comme tu dis de l'année
l'option djelic sachant que dans cet été
peut on peut rappeler que cette année
ont drafté deron sharp pivot de north
carolina qui va être un projet de
développement derrière tous les papiers
all-star blé griffin lamarcus aldridge
paul millsap et compagnie et puis ya
délit duke qui sort de providence qui
lui a fait un plus gros cursus mais qui
assigne un tout et donc je peux avoir
une équipe jean hugues très très
excitante
on en parle souvent le contexte
collectif toi quand tu as vu cameron
tomates cameron de masse honnête alors
au delà du du manteau ring a sévi dans
deuxième sardane khairi temps à penser
qu'on était assez content pour lui tu
t'es dit merde il va se faire moucher et
peut-être que ce mec là il jouera pas
dans les trois quatre prochaines années
bah pour dire la vérité j'étais assez
surpris
parce que
en fait les lignes assez rare pour les
commandes pour les contenders de
d'accueillir en autant de
de prospects en fait c'est dire ça c'est
quand même assez surprenant j'étais
aussi surpris qui hydrate autant les net
cette année après il faut que pour
justement pour comme mentor et là des
mentors tout trouvé qu'ils sont un peu
des supers attaquants tu vas pouvoir les
donner toutes les ficelles et tous et
pour lui ça je pense que c'est très très
bien quoi c'est très bien il peut très
vite se trouve être c'est pas être un
super sixième homme même lent de son
contrat rookie en fait qu'elle est un
espèce de panda une personne qui sort du
banc et qui en 20 minutes mais 15.3 tu
parler d'eric burdon alors gordon je
parlais de la comparaison physique mais
ça peut aussi être rares et les gordon
dans ce style là de sixième homme
est ce que à terme alors je trouve que
c'est un joueur cameron de basse pour
moi il n'a pas un énorme potentiel à
cause de ça de sa limitation de talent
et qu'on ait ces limitations athlétique
du fait que ce soit un arrière tueur
voilà c'est pas pour moi un énorme
potentiel mais par contre ça peut être
un excellent scoreur hyper fiable pour
moi à terme peut être un très très bon
teacher peut-être que ça sera pas
honnête mais qu'ils ont une équipe hyper
loaded mais ce que tu penses que ça peut
être aller jusque là un bon titulaire
dans une équipe de playoffs ou vraiment
tu le vois faire une carrière
entière de connaître en plaçant aimé que
tu va suspendre le montant mais qui
dépassera jamais voilà ce rôle de 6e 7e
8e
pas en fait il y a on va revenir à la
même chose ça va dépendre de lui de voir
s'il va être capable 1 de défendre et de
faire autre chose que tu en attaque est
ce qu'on l'a aussi très peu vu la
dernière à l'issue il faut le dire c'est
sur la création pour les autres qu'est
ce qu'il est capable de faire ce garçon
là dans ce secteur du jeu perso j'ai
beau avoir vu quasiment une vingtaine de
masse de aller sur l'année dernière je
sais pas je sais pas eu lieu parce que
ça jouait pas tant que ça donc ça va
être super intéressant à voir et s'il
arrive à gommer ses gros défauts quand
même
voilà après
c'est un jeune joueur c'est un mec qui
est fraîche manille il ya encore jeune
c'est un 2001 donc je suis je sais pas
c'est pour moi c'est un peu dans un
profil aussi dense que tu décrivait à
l'instant et un petit peu le côté tyler
héros quoi dire qu'on a fait un mec on
sait qu'il va mettre des points et ne
sais pas jusqu'à quel point elle peut
prendre de la place dans une franchise
en fait j'ai un peu le meut la même
problématique pour comme thomass
j'aime bien la comparaison gbl a comparé
à compter leurs héros il a fait une très
grosse première saison un peu
explique-t-il et puis d'aller à une mode
d'attenté on a vu que c'était plus
difficile et l'ac thann et il revient le
dit voilà est-ce que tu peux montrer que
tu peux créer aussi pour les autres il
développé ça ouais j'aime bien ça que
quand je regarde cameroun thomass a
comme thomas jeu je pense aussi un peu
tu vois abdillah leur buzz il avait fait
une incursion complaire aux mots clés ou
moi c'était un mec très référencé gros
scoreur mais voilà je me dis si
t'arrives pas à à devenir un créateur
collectif si t'arrives pas à prouver que
tu peux être une menace ballon en main
pour tout le monde un rôle à la bulle
biais de sa ne sont pas des kono pour
gallas genou je vois cette simili nous
pourrions assister à un croc shooter à
moi
ok bon bah écoute en tout cas je pense
qu'on a fait un profit leur
at on va juste je pense qu'on peut
rajouter sur le côté psy chic du garçon
bien sûr c'est assez peu expressif 5 on
n'a pas parlé sur un terrain acquis qu'à
paramo a l'air très basse elle écoute
mine de rien qu'une éducation assez dur
parce que enfin il est né au japon dans
une base militaire sa maman est midi
hier il a une mère qui a l'air d'être
assez haute en couleur celle qui a
beaucoup dicter ses choix il disait dans
un interview qu en fait le choix de les
chausser pour maman qui l'avait fait que
nuits maman l'a suivi à baton rouge il
habitait pas ensemble mais le surveiller
enfin la voilà
donc ça
soit c'est fusionnel avec n'est pas sans
rappeler adria rhin radio donc ça doit
être fait donc voilà c'est un petit
point bon finir
bah c'est vrai non mais tu sais bien de
revenir un peu sur son parcours quand tu
le dis il va aller sous c'est un mec qui
étudie depuis y est très très jeune les
premières offres qu'il a alors il a
signé lé soula comics en 2020 pour la
saison 5 en 2020 fin 2010 2020 il était
suivi par deux ans depuis 2010 est il
avait des offres depuis 2010 est on
parle de programme comme flo rida on
parle de programme comme
comme ucla voilà c'était un mec très
féroce est très très jeune
donc grosse attente grosse pression et
comme tu dis wildemond maman bien
présentes quoi exactement
ok bon je pense que cette fois ci on à
faire voilà un tour complet on a pu
parler du joueur n'a pas de son parcours
de ses points forts de ce qu'elle tacler
type de son rôle de ces projections
c'est un joueur que je vais attendre
fort que j'ai surveillé très fort et
j'ai hâte de voir évoluer je pense que
toi aussi longtemps qu'on s'adresse ici
et puis ben voilà n'hésitez pas du coup
à réagir sur ce papote on partage et à
le montrer aux femmes bennett montre aux
fans de quintaux masse
à venir parler avec maux de tête des
détails qu est-ce qui vous vous
embarquez si vous l'avez découvert qu
est ce qui vous a pris qu'est-ce qui
nous a moins plu et qu'on en discute
ensemble et qu'on réagisse pour pour
faire un petit peu vibrer la hype le
trac m tomasz exactement tous
très joli shoot shoot uffheim vachement
bien sûr ceux des bijoux tout le monde à
tout bientôt et puis les seconds cameron
torres
bye